this episode is sponsored by ground news
judge the truth for yourself
ground news is the world's first news
comparison platform it will let you see
how various media have processed
information and alert you to their
political point of view
this allows you to have a better
awareness of what you're reading via a
political spectrum tool see the news
that you're not seeing ground news is
geographic filters let you search
everything from hyper local news to
global events and with all the news
stories breaking about current events
these days you will be able to find
accurate statistics
and reliable facts news changes quickly
and cycles are shorter than ever but at
ground news you can keep track of all
the threads concerning your topics of
interest
refresh your memory on stories or just
observe the way
news spirals out you can also audit your
own news
yeah that's right they give you a simple
view of who has covered a story and
where each outlet falls on the political
spectrum you can get the ground news app
for free in both the apple app store and
the google play store
click the link in the description below
and get ground news for free now
let's get into today's video
[Applause]
[Music]
many people believe that buying things
on aliexpress is like giving money to
the chinese communist party reading some
media coverage
you get the impression that there is a
direct relationship between xi jinping
and chinese companies right well that's
not the case
listen up
[Music]
china halts 37 billion ant group ipo
citing major issues ft in case you don't
know
ant group is a financial services
company that is part of the alibaba
group and yes
alibaba is the parent company of
aliexpress we're talking about one of
the biggest and most well-known
companies in
all of china it is not only a technology
company that competes hand-in-hand with
the big giants of silicon valley it is
one of the chinese companies that has
gained the most market share
abroad however the chinese authorities
are putting all kinds of obstacles in
the way of ant group's ipo
there were even rumors about the alleged
disappearance of its founder jack ma he
disappeared from the public eye for
several months after giving a highly
controversial speech in shanghai in that
speech he harshly criticized chinese
banks but relax
jack ma has since reappeared and is safe
and sound nevertheless the chinese
government is still holding back the ipo
of his company and financial so the
questions that come up are what is
china's problem with its biggest tech
company why is the chinese government
making such a big deal about ant
financial going public
is it the chinese communist party
supposed to take care of its
entrepreneurs so that they can lead the
world today we're going to answer these
questions but first let's take a look at
a bit of history
financial institutions no longer win all
the time
in the last 25 years the chinese economy
has multiplied its size by precisely 25
times an absolute spectacular growth
record
[Music]
and of course given this data you may
even forget the most basic fact
no matter how many skyscrapers neon
lights and 5g antennas they have
china is still a communist country well
more of a kind of hybrid where they even
maintain five-year plans
and where the main banks in china belong
to the state yes it's true there are
private banks
but they are very small more than half
of chinese finance is in the hands of
the big
state-owned banks in reality this
translates into one thing the party
bureaucrats are the ones who ultimately
decide who can get a loan the priority
of these banks is not to lend to
households or small businesses but to
state-owned enterprises add to all this
the fact that chinese banking
regulations are much stricter than those
in europe or the united states
in other words if you're a small
business it is almost impossible to get
a bank to lend you money
to give you an idea less than one-fifth
of all chinese companies are backed by
banks by comparison in countries like
germany or spain
one in three companies borrow from banks
and that explains the criticism from
jack ma
that has hurt chinese banks so much
check it out
be wondering if banks don't lend money
how do regular chinese people get loans
how do they set up small businesses in
this country well through small money
lenders who charge very high interest
rates
many chinese have been sunk by unpayable
debts and so it was until ant financial
came along
ant financial is a global technology
company
it was founded on allypet established in
china as an escrow service
to build trust between online buyers and
sellers
since its first transaction alipay has
grown to be the world's largest digital
payment platform
and has now evolved from a digital
wallet to a lifestyle enabler
and i know what you're thinking let me
see if i've got this straight and
financial
alipay digital payment platforms what is
all this a new bank
well it's a company belonging to the
alibaba group but isn't alibaba
dedicated to e-commerce what are they
doing giving loans well we are going to
look at that
right now
jack ma's bank alibaba was founded in
1999.
at first it was a portal that connected
small chinese manufacturers with foreign
companies that wanted to buy wholesale
production from them then they moved on
to selling to end consumers
first in the chinese market with tmall
and taobao and finally to the whole
world with aliexpress
as of today alibaba handles 60 of
china's e-commerce and they dominate
nearly a third
of global e-commerce
alibaba is known around the world for
e-commerce but in china it goes even
further in 2004 they launched their own
payment platform
alipay from there they went on to
provide other financial services
loans to small and medium-sized
enterprises loans to individuals and
this
is how a new company was born within the
alibaba group and financial and this is
where the problems start for alibaba
because
it begins to offer services that were
traditionally offered by banks
this is something that we've already
covered on visualpolitik when we talked
about financial technology services
or fintech in the past banks manage the
entire relationship with money
now they don't now there are companies
like transferwise
dejiro or revolut a phenomenon that is
happening in china
in europe and all over the world but
there are some areas where ant is being
revolutionary
one is their uibal app upon opening
alipay and the uobao landing page
users can choose from a series of money
market funds
you can adjust your settings so that all
the funds from your alipay account will
be drawn from
and deposited directly into uobod
and you can also elect to have a certain
proportion of your salaries transferred
automatically each month eurobow is a
money market fund money market funds are
a little-known financial instrument
the way it works is this you put money
in uber and that money is invested to
give small loans to other people you get
a higher interest rate than if you put
your money in a regular term deposit
plus you can take it out whatever you
want and here comes the super advantage
there is no minimum amount technically
you can just invest 1u1 which would be
the equivalent of around 15 cents and
thanks to this feature this fund has
become a real bomb in china take a look
[Music]
alibaba's yue bao becomes world's
largest money market fund
cgtn uebel came to be managing up to 270
billion dollars in other words
ant group is a true financial revolution
and that is why this company's ipo
was going to be the biggest in history
that's right it was expected that they
would sell shares for a total of 37
billion dollars to give you an idea the
ipo of aramco the saudi arabian oil
company resulted in share sales of only
29 billion dollars
but months before the company went
public chinese financial regulators put
the brakes on the ipo
why well we're about to find out
[Music]
ideological reasons in addition to
ubival ant has continued to explore the
possibilities of fintech wealth
management
sme lending and all kinds of services
this is creating a gaping hole for
china's banks
studies claim that financial technology
firms will have eaten up more than 40
of china's potential card fees in less
than five years resulting in an annual
loss of around 60 billion dollars for
banks
[Music]
and not only that this displacement of
users from state-owned banks to fintech
entities such as ant group means that
banking in china would be privatized
with all that
this implies for the communist party in
terms of loss of control over the
chinese economy because to control
banking is to control the economy so the
reaction of the chinese authorities has
been very forceful
china's president xi jinping personally
scuttled jack ma's ant ipo
wall street journal but wait a moment
because this is not the only reason we
are not only talking about ideology but
also about a political game listen up
political reasons who is the biggest
beneficiary of a successful ipo well
those who already had part ownership in
the company in other words
those who own and financial shares
expect the share price to rise the
moment they enter the stock market
and who are among the biggest
[Music]
investment companies linked to the
grandson of former president jiang zumin
and the son-in-law a former politburo
standing committee member jiang ching
lin
stood to profit from the ipo the hindu
you see one of the first decisions that
xi jinping made as soon as he became
president of china was to
clean the party of corruption in other
words to throw out all his political
enemies
this is how he ended up taking total
control of the party well many of these
former party colleagues
have tried their luck in the corporate
world if this ipo were to take place
not only would they become millionaires
but they would also have ownership
of what would become the largest
financial institution in the country
that explains why it was as recently as
2020 that china took measures like this
beijing launches antitrust investigation
into alibaba financial times
it is curious that they start this
investigation right in the year 2020.
six years ago
one could justifiably argue that alibaba
was a monopoly
back then this company accounted for 81
of all e-commerce turnover in china
today however its market share has
fallen to 55
but hold on a minute because we're not
just talking about politics or ideology
there is actually an economic and quite
legitimate reason for wanting to put
some control on ant financial and we're
going to look at this right now
[Music]
economic policy reasons we could say
that ant financial is a bank that has
no money they just act as an
intermediary you ask for a loan amp
financial and they connect you with
small lenders or directly with banks and
financial is currently required by law
to fund only two percent of each loan
and here comes the big question what
happens if the debt isn't paid back
the problem would not be with the
intermediary but with the one who lends
you the money in other words and
financial has little incentive to make
sure that its clients are solvent
on the contrary their goal is to create
as many loans as possible
and what is the problem with all this
well it could easily trigger a lending
bubble a bubble very similar to the
sub-prime mortgage crisis
in other words and financial might be
willing to lend money to someone who is
not credit worthy
then it may bundle good debt and bad
debt into packages
these packages are then sold to banks or
investors
a lot of their customers are freaked out
waiting to see how low
everything and more has been completely
wiped out the dow traders are standing
there watching in amazement
i don't blame them well to avoid this
china has proposed this measure
china titans online lending rules in
fresh blow to jack ma's ant group
financial times
in short what the regulator's asking and
financial to do is put up 30 percent of
the money it lends out of its own pocket
this way the company has a strong
motivation to make sure that all of its
customers are credit worthy and yes
30 is a really high number to put it in
context banks in the eurozone are only
required to have a one percent reserve
in other words with these new
regulations and financial will be forced
to become much more conservative with
its lending almost as much as the
traditional chinese banks of course with
measures like this
they could also avoid a crisis like the
great recession of 2008 but on the other
hand they are preventing thousands of
small businesses from being able to
finance themselves
so now the question is do you think that
china's putting the brakes on alibaba's
financial arm is motivated by economics
or is it just a strategy for the chinese
communist party to maintain its control
over the economy you can leave your
answers in the comments below and as
always don't forget that here at
visualpolitik we have new videos every
week so don't forget to subscribe and
hit the little bell so you don't miss
any of our updates
all the best see you soon and if you
want to learn more about politics and
hear even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there